minutes before a family pulled out of
their driveway they got an alert from
their security system that Intruders
were inside their home that incident all
captured on surveillance camera Joshua
peguero has their story and also looks
at some of the best technology available
on the market to protect yourself
Boston Shin didn't think he'd ever deal
with a burglary in his quiet Summerlin
neighborhood on Wednesday though his
family sense of security was shattered
like I was working and then my wife was
uh you know afterwards she you know
drugging on home we just the pop-up and
some guys are going to be on like inside
my living room and if she just freaked
out because her two guys are gonna be
inside of my house his wife and two
daughters are now avoiding the house
they've lived in for 15 years again uh
after that happened she not gonna come
into home she's still crying yes
I'm sorry
according to Shin the thieves stole
items like boxes of cigarettes watches a
basketball jersey and a hat his neighbor
Adam Graham also expressed concern I
have recently became a father on New
Year's Day so it was uh now now that I
am a father it's so much more the safety
is so much more important I have a
family now to protect as you can see
there are different options for
surveillance cameras but one of the most
popular ones mostly because they're
cheaper are the ring cameras but these
cameras do come with their downsides for
hazard Rudd of Las Vegas Tech solution
says ring cameras rely on Wi-Fi which
isn't reliable you might want to have
your your cameras hardwired to the
system and you might want to hide your
NVR or DVR the recorder box somewhere
that's not really obvious what also
recommends getting a metal camera rather
than a plastic one to withstand the Las
Vegas heat Joshua preguero eight news
now
that's scary a hard-wired metal
surveillance camera will run you between
75 to 100 should last up to five years
too